this is not your grandma's kind of
geometry proof
uh you've done plenty of geometry proofs
in your years
of maths but usually you get one diagram
one situation and they say prove
something about this okay
this time i've got an infinite number of
diagrams okay which is why you can see
this is suitable
for a proof by induction okay so
how are we going to do this how are we
going to approach it well we're going to
start off
by approaching it the way that we
usually do which is
by testing the first allowable value
which is given to us
right so i'm going to test
for it equals three now of course i've
been mentioning the fact that
occasionally
your first level value even though it
almost always is it's not always one and
there's an obvious reason for this one a
geometrical one
that's why you don't just blindly start
off with the first positive integer
okay so n equals three now before i test
it
how how should i go about testing it now
in this case
come on in in this case it'll be fine
just to draw a diagram that shows a
three-sided convex polygon
and then get the result out from that
right but
i do want some equations that i can work
with even though for the test case it's
not that important
later on when i'm doing some
manipulation with the algebra
i'm going to need equations to work with
okay so
let's let the number of diagonals here
right let's let's just give it an a okay
so let
d of n be the number of diagonals
okay so i'm going to test for df3 right
e3 is it equal to what we expect it to
be equal to well it's three on
two times three minus three that's one
and a half times zero
that's zero is that what you expected it
is
and just to be sure yourself a diagram
there
and how many diagonals does it have it
doesn't have any
okay now just even though we don't
need to in this case just from my own
curiosity because i find that a bit of a
that's a bit of a weird result okay i'm
just going to test the next one just for
the sake of it okay
if n equals four right
how does it work out if you do d of four
you get
four over two times four minus three
okay two times one that's two
okay that that does check out right look
here's a try hard to not draw a regular
anything that's pretty regular isn't it
kind of looks like a kite
anyway now you can see how many
diagonals are there
there's the two you expect one
two great okay so we've tested for our
first allowable value
so far so good step two is
assume assume now by the
way i've i've been watching you working
out as you've been doing this right
please do not write assume that n equals
k
assume that n equals k
there's a difference here what you
should say is assume
true and you're implying assume this
statement
this statement is true for n equals k
right because assuming n equals and n
can be anything you like
right so sure make it k if you want
eventually we'll get to
some number k right that doesn't mean
anything i'm interested in this whole
statement
okay so you can't leave this thing out
okay you can't just say assume n equals
k
that's not enough what would that mean
it would mean this d of k is equal to
k on 2 k
minus 3. i should have also included the
condition for k
where it's 3 five and so on
okay there's my assumption
all right now what am i required to
prove
is my proof step okay well i want the
next case over
k plus one by the way here's a good
moment for me to mention that
just like your first level value is not
always one
right your immediate next case
is not always k plus one and you might
have seen one of the questions
that i gave you i can't remember which
heading it was under but the actual
values that were interested here
were not one integer the next integer
the next ninja
i think the example i gave you was odd
integers so it's one three
five seven and so on okay in which case
what would the next allowable case be
it'll be cables too wouldn't it and um
it leaves out the even ones it has to
uh and if you try it and you try cables
one it rapidly breaks down
okay so be careful little traps to fall
into
what's it look like k plus one on two
and this will become
k minus two yeah
okay now everything so far has been on
autopilot
because you just you do this you tick
the boxes you get to here
but now what where do you even begin
okay uh do you do you start by writing
this assumption down and then try and
work
with it in order to um like we did with
inequalities yesterday
or do you start with one of these sides
and then try and do some algebra stuff
to it
to put in your assumption
stare at with at it with me for a second
what kind of alternatives do we have
here
does anyone have any suggestions what we
might do what might be a
valuable starting point for us
you remember i said yesterday that for
each different variety of proof
right and this is a geometry proof okay
this proof look this proof step here is
slightly different
right you do slightly different things
because what you're trying to prove is
slightly different
okay they're interested in different
properties truths etc
being that this is geometry
i could ask this in two ways i was going
to ask what's your first instinct
with a geometry proof but what i think i
might ask instead is
what should your first instinct be even
if it's not right now
what do i always bang on about when we
look at geometry proofs
that's not a bad idea now there's a
problem of course with drawing a diagram
because as i said
you know what does this thing look like
i don't know how many sides it has
well when we have a series right you've
been looking at things like this
one oops sorry plus two plus three if i
said i want this series to go on for a
long time but i don't know
how long right i want n terms
you know what the last term will be
right but you don't know how many
numbers are in between so what do we do
you put dots don't you you say there's
some number of terms
who knows okay i'm gonna do exactly the
same thing
here i have a polygon i know it's convex
that's important by the way because you
know if it was um
it was concave it had sides that went in
instead of outwards then the diagonals
would change
right i know what convex polygons look
like let's start one off okay
let's let a polygon be defined by
now we usually name polygons like oh
okay
a b c right or
a b c d so our convention at the moment
is we use capital letters and we go in
series okay
this might not be such a good idea here
because
what if there are more than 26 sides
which is possible right
so instead i'm going to call them well
they're all these are all points
right okay so i'm going to call them p1
for the first point p2 from the next
point
p3 now at this point you get three
points you've got a pattern
you say dot dot dot i don't know how far
i go
now hold on a second how many points
will there be
how many points will there be
not that complicated question
the the last point will be p of what
this is n sided right three signs
i have one two three points
right right four sided figure
one two three four
now here i have a k plus
one sided thing okay so i'm gonna have p
k there
and then the very last one will be p k
plus one so far so good
how do you draw it well
place a point down okay unfortunately i
cannot draw this accurately
um well actually i don't know what any
of the angles are really going to be i'm
just going to draw off some
interval to get to my next point okay
and then i'll draw off another interval
to get to
the next point okay but then i have dots
right so i'll go dot dot dot
maybe a few more dots let's make it
reasonably sized
and then after some number of dots i
will have the k
point okay the next one of course
is the k plus one point
now what happens
this is the last point isn't it right
now when i come to the last point
usually
sorry this last point or this last point
in order to make it a polygon i've got
to
i've got to close the shape right so
this guy comes right back over here is
that okay
see what i've got okay good
now there's my shape i want to start
doing some work with this right but
don't forget this is an induction proof
right so in order to prove this i'm
going to use this
somehow the question is where is the
assumption
where is it hiding in what i've got here
okay
and the answer is well it's it's
it's here isn't it i can draw it uh
maybe i use i'll stick with this
there it is there is a polygon with k
points
k sides okay so i'm assuming something
about the number
of diagonals that are over here okay now
before i go any further
don't put this down on your proof but
maybe you do want to draw it on the side
so you can understand what's going on
this is difficult to work with
conceptually because it's abstract
right we can't picture it you've got
dots in there okay so to make things
easier for yourself
and understand what's going on take a
concrete example first this is a classic
problem-solving
um technique okay so let's think of one
you know about like say a pentagon
here's a pentagon okay how many
diagonals does it have
come on you have a formula come on it's
got five sides
five on two five minus three
it's five isn't it five and let's just
make sure we can count them
okay i count one two
three four
five good okay now
just take that five take that as our k
right
now what difference would it make if i
went to k plus one okay
well you add another side to add another
side you add another
point yes okay so
let me um which color should i decide
let's add another point over here
okay there's my sixth point my k plus
one point
okay so now if i extend the polygon over
here
that new shape is a hexagon yes
now how many diagonals will it have now
you can view it from this point of view
right another way to think about it is
this new hexagon right
it will still have all the old diagonals
that i drew in green
won't it all those guys are still
legitimate diagonals of this new figure
i just have those diagonals plus a few
extra ones
right where are the extra ones
they're all reaching from my existing
points
over to the new point i just introduced
or if you want to think about the other
way
from this point to all of the possible
diagonals i could form
okay i can't form diagonals everywhere i
can't form diagonals with adjacent
points
right how many can i form
it looks to me like i can form one
two three what i
missed you get the idea okay did you see
that
i missed one blue one
uh yeah okay all right so so this guy
here
right which was aside before wasn't it
okay
so i have extra diagonals extra
diagonals
all the previous diagonals the green
ones right
and new ones in red
five plus four
you content with that okay now how can i
bring this over here
right i can say that this shape in here
right and i actually have a name for it
don't i if this is abc
and this is a b c d what's this polygon
called
it's called p1p2 p3
pk right how many diagonals does it have
it has well by assumption
it has that many diagonals right okay
on two k minus
three diagonal
okay uh by assumption
so tick it's a proof by induction now
because i used an assumption okay
now how do i get from that shape to the
next one well i'll do the same thing i
did here
right i have to add on a new series of
diagonals don't i
okay so this new shape p1 p2
p3 and so on pk and i have to include
the last point
right has that many
whoops plus now
how many new diagonals have i got
where does this four come from where
does this four come from
well i can reach all of these points
that are across
from here right and then i get one bonus
new one
okay how many will there be
if you want to think about it this way
right from this point
there are two points that i cannot form
a diagonal with
two points i cannot form a diagonal with
right
i suppose you could say this three
because i can't form a diagonal with
myself
right so that's why i get three here but
i'll always get
one more which is not from this point
right
so it's four this is surely this is n
minus two right six sides
six sides right one two three
four if i made a seventh side hmm
is it going to work let's try it shall
we
what would happen okay let me do it
dotted see what we can do
i can do one new one here one two new
ones here
three four aha
five it's still n minus two isn't it
okay so here i'll have
all the original diagonals and then
new diagonals is that all right see what
i've done
if you like you can illustrate on this
guy as well you've got
this this and that old side which is now
a diagonal
okay so what's that equal to
that's equal to uh
i've got what have i got here um let's
put this on a common denominator shall
we that's k
k minus three plus two k minus 2
all on 2. is that all right i'm going to
keep the 2 around because
i know i'm going to need one in the end
so there's no point getting rid of it
okay oh my god uh k squared minus 3
k plus 2 k minus 2
4 sorry thank you all on 2.
k squared's still there minus k
minus wait sorry i missed something yes
yes yes yes
yes this is minus one isn't it but yeah
that's better
because i i do need a two here that's
how i'm going to factorize
two that's why we've done two in the
first place
uh two on two and this of course you can
factorize can't you
right that's your k plus one k minus two
which is exactly what you're expecting
that's this so it works
okay so always different
this is not like the inequality proof
where you start off with the assumption
okay i actually think it's very much
like the ones you started with
where you work with this but you need a
picture don't you
it is harder to work with in abstract so
you do concrete ones and then you can
see the pattern
right and then you can form the algebra
and stick the assumption in
does that make sense